here we go we're in it
hello everybody welcome back to the
corridor cast
we're here we're talking do the intro
today
wait my voice doesn't sound that high
right now
today we've got some special guests we
got jake we got peter clint and myself
hey guys okay wow uh
so there may be a reason why you
know that ren is using helium and that's
because this is a special
this is a corridor podcast special uh
because we're gonna talk about the up
video
the up video okay is my voice back to
normal i can't really tell
what's up we're going to get back to
normal that's pretty much that's too bad
let's
fix that am i right
inhaling yeah no i would die
um this oh my goodness
why don't you just suck it right out of
the tank dude yeah please
because i don't want to infect the tank
with me it's already infected with you
you just put your mouth on it then put
that back on there though
yeah i know that's it that's pretty much
exactly what i'm doing so no one else is
allowed to use the helium anymore except
for me it's all mine
mine forever you're a pro it's sucking
in that dude
okay the issue with helium though is
that you have to take a lot of breaths
between
each uh helium suck otherwise you will
not get enough oxygen and you might pass
out
but you're used to that kind of stuff so
it's okay no okay
before we get into anything i want to
talk about
people's perception of how helium
affects the body because i have been
called a helium addict
more times in the last day and i'm
pretty sure any human being on the
planet has ever been called a helium
addict
yeah i i've been called a helium like
not a heliomatic but like hey you're
you should slow down on the helium man
like helium during the day is like
that's when you know you're pushing it a
little bit
yeah so i guess before we get into that
even so
i'm about healing before bed kind of guy
today
let's see today's monday the giant uh
up video that we put out came out
yesterday it has been a little over 24
hours and the video already has a
million views
feels great that's that's a great
success that i'm very happy about that
very pleased
um but yeah uh there's a lot of work
that i wanted to
would what is it what yeah
it for the people who don't know what is
it yeah what is what the up video what's
that
the movie up it came out 2008 it
features this house flying away on
balloons
and that is it's a really cool image
like the imagery of that movie i think
is very iconic
and uh i forget when i learned this but
i remember learning that like all right
it wasn't actually real because
to actually lift a house you'd need so
many more balloons
and i was like man that's that could be
a cool scale video but i like i i tucked
it away
for like later and then like last fall
film theory
uh the film theorist channel they put
out a video kind of detailing and
analyzing how many balloons would be
needed
and that was kind of like okay that's
pretty cool and then i got to thinking
but
they didn't actually show anything you
know they're all about like the 2d
illustrations and just kind of
discussing uh the you know the message
the the theory and the ideas yeah the
thought experiment of it i think that's
the first question everyone asks though
when they watch that movie is they go
is that how many balloons it would
really take is it is that the first
question that's
that's the first question that i asked
like is that possible like is that
actually possible you know
and yeah and fortunately this is not a
hard thing to calculate it's just
it's it's a simple like like measuring
scale type
measuring i say measuring measuring
um for the record no the helium is not
affecting me that's not
there's i got people who got aggressive
on my instagram
one guy said uh i'm not gonna shed a
tear when you die from lung disease
whoa because he was like he's like
you're you're like you're
you're setting the wrong example for
your young audience as if he's assuming
the age range of my personal audience
is he pissed at logan paul as well
uh but here's the thing there are a lot
of people like hey man you should maybe
like cut back on the helium it's bad for
you
and the true answer is that it's not bad
for you helium is a noble gas
it's inert uh i don't know what that
means
it means it doesn't react with anything
oh so it doesn't it doesn't go like
inside of you the danger there is it's
not to say that there is no danger with
uh
sucking up helium uh the danger comes
from the fact that it displaces
oxygen and oxygen is what your body
needs to
live uh right it's what your brain needs
it's it's basically every time you take
a big breath of helium
it's the equivalent of holding your
breath so
if you if you have too much of it
too soon you could pass out yes i have
done that before so when's the last time
that happened college
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
red i find this hard to believe
you've passed out from ingesting too
much helium
his senior design project in engineering
he designed a blimp from scratch
uh did you suck up all things we did
yeah no because like we put all the
helium in the balloon and then it's like
well
we did the experiment we we filmed our
little video for it now it's just
we're gonna open it up and release into
the atmosphere now we're gonna we're
gonna
freaking suck it so we did um and i
thought i made a little video about it
um basically my friend and
my other friend kind of were just
explaining how the blimp worked to each
other but the entire thing is just
entirely them
on helium oh my god and it's just like
never really addressed
um that's great but yeah then i started
trying and i started breathing in i i'd
take a big breath
start talking take another big breath
start talking and then on my
third breath i was like and i started
talking and then next thing i know i'm
on the ground
oh my god i'm like hey oh no ron just
bonked his head
bonked my head on his head he's like
some helium for that dude
and so like i just momentarily passed
out because like my brain wasn't getting
enough oxygen so
you start to black out fortunately the
cure to that is just to keep breathing
which your body does naturally when you
pass out
so it's like it's incredibly difficult
to actually harm yourself from helium
like passing out like that's not that
bad for you no worse than you know
bad night of drinking i guess so i feel
like a bed and i drink me way worse
that's what i'm saying significantly
worse a little bit of healing and yeah
so that's like the only
like danger involved with helium and
it's not even that bad of a danger
so as far as the actual exposure to
helium it's because
the in the two videos leading up to that
uh yesterday's video i i had like a line
of healing so now everyone thinks
hey would it be as safe if you used
hydrogen instead
i don't know hydrogen i would i would
never
oh my god dude i would just hold it
lighter next to your mouth yeah dude no
you don't mess around with hydrogen
hydrogen is like
legit scary because it's super flammable
it's incredibly flammable it's like
incredibly realistic
and then like lit a little flame could
you like
spit fire or would it go into your lungs
it would go into your lungs and your
chest would explode
ugh i i okay i don't know that for a
fact that is my guess that is my
hypothesis
i mean well it does explode i have a
friend who their family on new year's
would send up hydrogen weather balloons
and shoot them with flaming arrows
see that is cool like you can totally do
that like i've heard of people
like filling up hydrogen balloons and
it's like hey watch this and you explode
it my dad
uh told me about a story uh his college
physics class he uh
they would have two balloons one was
helium one was hydrogen and he would
take a lighter on a stick
to the helium balloon and it would pop
and it's like i was like wow
balloon go pop cool and then he did the
same thing to the hydrogen balloon and
like
everyone's ears were ringing after that
because it was like fireball it was very
loud very explosive
that's hydrogen does not mess around
well
it's like yeah is there any way to make
it not flammable
hydrogen or would you have to change its
chemical compound you would have to like
you'd have to create a compound by
merging it with something else
like uh i mean like h2
is how hydrogen exists in the atmosphere
and if you combine that with oxygen
one of the only other things that really
combines with naturally i think chemists
don't don't then you don't want to don't
at me obviously
uh and that makes water how does two
gases make a water
that's crazy i know all right crazy
we're not here to solve
chemistry's most complex questions yeah
clint that's no i'm just doing one you
know but you're right you go ahead jake
i'm just kidding i was just trying to
razz you a little bit no we're here to
talk about some up video you know
yeah i well i don't know man
i don't know we can talk about whatever
we want here this is okay because i just
i just want to get that helium stuff off
my chest because i have been
getting more comments about how i should
stop being a danger to myself
in the last day than all the times i've
actually legitimately been a danger to
myself
can you please come on can you please
hit that helium tank right now from the
teeth
from the yeah please yeah okay hit it
from the source
exhale exhale completely
hit it from the source oh
jesus here it goes
okay i'm getting lightheaded now now
we're entering actual legit danger
territory but i've got supervision here
and that's okay my voice is back to
normal hey look at that
no more spots we're going to talk about
our sponsors today storyblocks because i
actually used it a ton
in the up video so i kind of just want
to talk about that real quick they've
got unlimited downloads they've got like
a million options to choose from
and their subscription plans are really
affordable so here's the thing for this
up video i filmed a lot
but at the same time i'm not going to be
able to go to all these different places
that i would love to be able to go to
to be able to film for this video and
that's where storyblocks comes in
the entire segment where i'm talking
about mining helium
that's all stock footage they have so
much 4k footage now too
quality also they have after effects
templates you can literally just browse
for like what's a cool little transition
or type of
effect that i can do without having to
put any effort or work into it
download it and make your little
alterations you need doing it this way
with unlimited downloads
opens up the freedom to create more
effectively check it out link in the
description if you're interested
helps us out it might help you out
storyblocks.com quartercast or
the link in the description like i said
but for now let's get back to chatting
about
up are you down for that i'm down for up
i'm gonna do it again oh my god
this is the most danger i put myself in
regarding this helium tank
through this entire year so far and you
guys are witnessing it in real time
this is the most dangerous i've ran do
you ever
do you ever go home and like and
you show up and jen is there and you're
like i just want you to know how
dangerous i was today
strapped to the back of it
yeah no i i've done permutations of that
where i kind of like i tell her i come
home and i'm like hey babe
i uh i did i did this today andre like
looks at me
and then looks away and she's like of
course you did she's like
not surprised by any stunts i pull
anymore oh my goodness dude there isn't
you think you guys see a lot of stunts
that i pull
how do you think she deals with life she
sees
a lot more me and um me and kim were
watching
avatar the last airbender last night and
uh there was an episode where they were
stuck in the desert and saka like
ate this cactus and he started eating
the cactus juice and he got
super high and like for a whole episode
he was like
all wigged out and then as soon as he
like gets back to normal
like they're in a cave and he just looks
and he sees this like goop on the side
of the wall and he just eats it he just
licks it and i'm like
that's wren like that character is very
similar to randy
yeah yeah i was like that's straight up
ren he'll eat anything
dude i i got a text from my heist my my
college roommate
uh good friend of mine but i hadn't
talked to him in years
and he i get a text from him out of the
blues saying that he'd been catching up
on corridor
crew videos this is like a year or two
ago right
and he's like ren you put more stuff in
your mouth than my two-year-old son
oh man and i was like damn straight
where does this come from this it's
comfortableness
with putting things in your mouth it's
it's to get a reaction i'm very much so
an attention seeker it's like it's
in my dna of just like trying to get
reactions out of people it's the camera
like ren
dude it's not just the camera it's it's
anyone it's like if i know someone's
watching
it's i'm automatically in like
performance mode and it's subtle
it's it but it's there like when you
ride your one wheel and you crash and
then you see a crowd you always do like
the little bow
i do yeah well it's because that's just
how i deal with embarrassment more than
anything
yeah like if yeah if if i like freaking
biff it in front of people like what are
you gonna do like get up and walk away
it's like that's so embarrassing but if
you embrace it
and you stand up and you're like i do a
curtsy yes like
yeah that's great like i'm aware
that you're aware that i've just
embarrassed myself and i'm just gonna do
a curtsy because that's even more
embarrassing and
you'll remember that you remember that
and not the fall
i don't know what's the worst thing
you've eaten sorry just last
before we move on like coin juice was
pretty bad oranges
okay and to be clear i don't eat any of
those things
i chew them and spit them out
what was the word like i don't swallow
or ingest how do you how exactly do you
chew coin juice
no i sipped it and then you can see in
the video i immediately spit it all out
that's true you do it tasted like
freaking salty blood water
aren't you worried about getting an
infection or something not an infection
the iodine not the iodine whatever the
freaking sodium chloride stuff was in
that
it's just a it's a metallurgy type thing
it's ions breaking off from the
the the coin and attaching to the fork
that he had in there and it's just like
the transfer so that solution kind of
becomes more
whatever i don't know the details but
it's just it's just really salty water
that had a metallic taste to it
it was awful um i mean
tree leaf was bad that's just gross it's
just bitter
and wait i was there for that i looked
at you and i was like
i dared to eat that tree leaf or
something like that you just ate it
you're like that was
how about a banana peel oh god wait no
that's right when was that because that
didn't make it into the video
yeah i don't remember but i just we're
going to park filming something and like
you ate it
like i didn't even i looked at you from
like super far away
and i was like get this tree leaf and
like you we didn't you didn't have to
say anything
like you just ate it i don't remember
when that was because i think we also
did that when we were rescuing the drone
out of the tree last year yeah but you
weren't there for that no i remember
like i think wes handed me something i
was like god don't do it don't do it
don't offer it to me because i'll have
to eat it i haven't
done it i thought that was a tree leaf i
guess maybe it's something else
we had a banana peel too right yeah i
mean there's the whole uh running gag in
the guillotine channel every time you
guys chopped fruit i just ate it skin
and all like the pineapple
yeah on it honestly the pineapple skin
was the best
compared to uh cantaloupe and banana
huh yeah interesting if i brought a bag
of broccoli to work and i was like hey
ren eat this
like every hour would you just eat a
piece of broccoli you get so healthy
i like broccoli okay cool cool like
low-key just trying to help him out i
mean
i like it better when it's been like
roasted but like no it's gonna be frozen
no i mean broccoli dude i was just
trying to help you out i just thought
maybe
you know you wanted some
all right uh let's talk about this video
though yeah yeah so i mean
red the people want to know uh i mean
how how long
did it take to make it where did it
where did the idea come from you kind of
already answered that
what were the post-production challenges
you faced all that stuff
yeah so i mean like i came up with the
idea a while ago and i noted it down
like more than two years ago and it was
last fall
shooting or writing my script for
functional filmmaking and i had an
example where i talk about
or rather part of my episode is is
talking about
i mean most of my episode is talking
about ideas but um
i i basically say you gotta like write
down ideas and i pull up my phone and as
i'm like
scrolling through i'm like how many
balloons would it take to lift a house
and i'm like
that's actually a really good idea i
should do that and and
then like i did
but here's the thing that functional
filmmaking episode isn't out yet
and yeah and so in that video i'm gonna
be talking about like oh i should do
this and then like but
that video that i'm talking about i
should do is already ancient history at
this point i mean it just shows how on
it you are you know i mean i suppose uh
do you guys clinton peter do you guys do
that does that like do you write down
ideas on your phone or oh yeah like i
have like consistently
hundreds of just nonsensical notes on my
phone i'm like what was i even talking
about when i wrote this down yeah
yeah note stock google google doc
anything to get an idea as quick as
possible
trello yeah you got me hooked on that
trello oh you you got ideas on trello
yeah i got a whole idea board it's like
a trello it's just like a management
like a cool thing yeah yeah it's got
some
trello ideas son yeah i have a question
for you
so you have all of these ideas for
different videos like the science videos
what is your process for like weeding
out the good ones and
finally selecting one to work you know
that's a good question maybe you should
subscribe to corridor digital.com to see
my functional phone oh i don't want to
give it a go
i i only briefly touch on that uh but
because that is actually a more specific
question than what i cover in the
episode um
let's see uh it's it comes down to like
how easy no how well would this
how do i weed out all like the the good
ideas from the bad ideas right
and it comes down to how much can i riff
on this idea
between different topics and how would
that look on camera
because i've there have been some ideas
that like
it's it's a good idea i'd love to see
the scale of you know this thing
compared to something else but it's like
that's the extent of the idea right and
it's like that
is kind of just it it's like just one
thing it's like they would make a great
30 second video
so how naturally the idea like can be
expressed or uh
different avenues you get on different
avenues
the interest that another person would
have in
that well it's more so like the
subtopics within it so like
you know the scale of the universe the
scale of atoms those two videos
there's like multiple different things
within that video that i can talk about
yeah like and and it just so happens
that like i'm able to just walk down the
list of scale like starting with atoms
you know i could talk about like you
know atoms moving up to molecules red
blood cells
salt crystals uh pennies
and then going down to mega tiny with
like you know neutrinos and the plank
length and stuff like that
stars a few different stars star wars
ships a few different ships uh
and and so when i don't have all those
different things it can kind of be
a struggle to write like the the how
much water is on earth video was a
struggle to write because it's like
it's this much
yeah how do i make a video i had that
it's like okay so then it's like i'm
trying to come up with like different
ideas that i can extrapolate from
uh and this up video was kind of that
where it's like okay
i mean like what would it look like i
could i could easily just be like all
right it's this many balloons and it
would look like this
but the video ended up kind of turning
into more of a thing talking about
buoyancy in general and balloons in
general that's why i talk about
helium that's why i talk about hydrogen
that's why i talk about vacuum
i really wish i could have added a
little bit of segment talking about hot
air balloons
because hot air balloons are lighter
than air kind of like helium
yeah um and
it i don't know it just it didn't it
didn't it
it ended up not really fitting in the
video because hot air is lighter than
regular air because
hot air is expands so it's less dense
and it's just it's like it's that's how
birds can go up
right yeah they ride there because
you're writing yeah birds write a
thermal and a thermal is just uh
hotter air and because it's hotter it's
rising up and birds get into that pocket
of air that's or it's like jumping on
it's like getting on an elevator
yeah like those elevators that never
stop and you just like you hook yourself
on you just go
those aren't real elevators but you know
what i mean yeah um
air balloons you can't freaking steer
them that's nuts
once you get up it's like how do you
know you're going to get down you can
you can control your
elevation pretty easily yeah you can
control your rate of descent and rate of
ascension
uh but yes control your direction so
it's like if you know you're about to
hit something you just go up and over it
and find a good landing spot on the
other side
well yeah it's uh you have more control
than you initially think
but you're right you are still riding on
the wind
wild riding on the wind boys we're all
riding on the wind
but yeah like another video i wanted i
want to do is talking about like
uh the scale of data usage and i haven't
even started writing this at all
too much i've done a little bit of
preliminary research but by the time you
from the time you work on that video to
the time it releases
that the scale of data will change dude
that's a good point that's actually a
really cool point like
you could say from the time i started
working on this video and then also from
the time you started
listening to this video this is how much
data has been added
to everything like great idea that's
crazy it's a solid idea like that puts
it in perspective
at this point in the video but then i'm
gonna like lock myself into making sure
that that moment in the video is right
at that second
yeah but you you know you can figure it
out like you guesstimate it but that's
pretty that's a really cool idea
but yeah and just kind of going through
and like okay starting with like floppy
disk drives how much
if you're to put all of the world's data
on floppy disk drives what would that
look like it'd be like a giant
giant pile of floppy disks and just like
just today youtube has
you know this yeah you always see that
that metric of like youtube uploads 493
trillion years worth of
video every second and obviously that's
an example i don't know the real numbers
943 trillion years a second
hey man i don't think it's that high
yeah
yeah but that's that's all really cool
stuff to play with but yeah it's i don't
know i i feel like if
if i hear it's it's more about the
the idea behind the visual than
just the visual itself because i'm
constantly getting you know messages
like oh you should you should compare
these things and it's like
they're shallow and that's what it comes
down to is like i'm measuring the depth
in my head of
what can i do with this idea where can i
go with it where can i explore because
it got legs
yeah yeah because well i mean if you
visualize something
and it doesn't have any relation to
the viewer in any way like if the viewer
can't look at it and go
that's interesting not just because of
the image but also because of the image
teaches me this
you know that that that underlying
thing yeah and it's like i've definitely
kind of like
tried to figure out how far into because
these videos are definitely in the
category of edutainment
where it's a combination of uh education
and entertainment and i'm constantly
kind of shifting back and forth between
like
being a little bit more educational
being a little bit more entertaining i
think this up video's
slightly leaned more towards
entertainment than education because i
i kind of like completely glossed over
any of the actual like math that was
done
right and and like because people kept
asking like did you include the weight
of the strings and i'm like did you
watch the video i literally wrote out i
included the weight of the strings
but it was i was on the screen for like
one second i don't know um
but i did technically kind of
uh it's like okay i think the real
calculation came out to around 75 000
balloons
weather balloons but that was not taking
into account the weight of
any string or mounting framer because
realistically it probably wouldn't be
string it'd probably be some sort of
buttress that goes up
and out for all the balloons to attach
to and it's like
all right now that's starting to get too
far into the weeds of trying to figure
out
like realistically figure out this
totally hypothetical thing it's like
okay whatever
so i was like okay i rounded it up to 80
000 balloons and worked backwards
how much weight extra would that be and
it came out to like 43 000 pounds
of extra weight and i'm like that's
enough string
that's that's enough oh my god sure
let's make it 80 000 pounds and i'm just
gonna say that
i did there's a lot of
oversimplification here it's like i did
all the back work on the math and all
that stuff but like
this this video's you're here to watch
some balloons lift a house like you're
not here to learn about like the
specific equations i used
did you um did your uh calculations come
out to be
similar to that other video that came
out a while ago that you referenced
oh the film theory video yeah i mean
kind of a good question uh it
i think it should probably be fewer
balloons than they came out too but
here's the thing i decided to just use
their number
rather than use whatever i did because
it's like all right they already have a
pretty good video kind of diving into
the analysis because what it comes down
to
is how much does this house weigh and i
could use the average weight of a house
and figure it out for that but here but
honestly the main reason why i decided
to go with their number is because it
was bigger
hey so why why does a queen anne house
weigh so much more than a regular house
so a queen and style house is a much
older style house and
traditionally older houses use denser
materials they're heavier in general
they've got a whole lot of like extra
wood and like we're talking like
high quality dense wood that's very
heavy
and and all like the extra like parapets
and like shale
uh or not shale the tiles yeah and the
crabs
houses have gotten more efficient over
time and that means they've
you know they're using lighter materials
cheaper materials that tend to be
lighter
as a byproduct yeah um
so i was like all right i can figure
this out and using
a hundred and twenty thousand pounds as
the weight of the house
but it would it would have this many
balloons and i was like
i mean i could do that or i can make it
what they said which was 570 000 pounds
for this house and that would require
this many balloons
there's no upper limit on how many
balloons we can put on this house might
as well make the more impressive visual
right and there's precedent behind the
number it's not like i'm just
arbitrarily
making it a bigger house i'm choosing
the bigger option because someone else
has already been like you know what i
am making a stand that this is how much
the house weighs here's my reasoning
behind it i'm going and i'm basically
just being like
i like the reasoning i'm choosing their
numbers you know don't at me
yeah totally okay did that calculation
include the basement and the strings
though no it included the strings but it
did not include the basement
because it lifts away from the
foundation but to find china
in the house yeah i don't know
they basically based it off of this one
company that estimated that the weight
per square foot of that style of house
to be around 275-ish feet
sorry pounds per square foot well hold
on to put it into perspective though
200 pounds for this yeah wow to put it
into perspective you said that that
weighs more than the statue of liberty
yeah that is crazy yeah like i i it was
really hard for me to believe that
is the statue of liberty made of like
paper mache no it's made out of
copper copper yeah and it's heavier than
that
yeah that's why it turned green right it
is white turned green yeah
um but also don't forget the statue of
liberty is hollow
yeah it's just a thin sheet of metal on
the outside that's been like hammered
into shape
yeah and that that is the bulk of the
weight of the statue
and but then you have all the metal
framework inside of the statue kind of
helping it keep its shape
yeah and that's steel and the stairs and
stuff like that
uh yeah the stairs the you know and
that's an additional weight but it's not
as much as a statue as a whole
and we are it's very important to note
we are not including the weight of the
concrete foundation
okay that weighs like 50 000 tons
yeah that'd be a lot 50 million tons oh
my goodness
something something astronomically heavy
because it's like a giant islands worth
of
concrete whereas the statue itself that
was also to scale that shot with the
house and the
windmill and the the statue like that is
to scale the statue of liberty's not
that big it's 150 feet tall right yeah
but the foundation puts it up to 300
feet tall so it's like
half his statue half his foundation wow
did did you include the empty space
inside the house
when you got the weight of it no that's
a good question it
so that number that i mentioned is is an
average for that style of house so it's
like it's not like they're saying if
you're just to cut out a square foot of
the house is going to weigh 200 pounds
it's like all right right but if they're
like hey it's a 2 000 square foot house
at 275
pounds per square foot right the volume
of it you mean like the volume
did you include the volume in that no
because it's not airtight so the volume
inside of the house doesn't count okay
yeah so uh
you're just counting like yeah i mean
like the doors the windows they're not
sealed they're you know he opens them
all the time and that air equalizes out
to the outside
yeah uh if he was like to you know to
like seal everything down then you would
have to take into account the weight of
the air
yeah but because it's not a factor
uh well but yeah so let's talk about
some visual effects
oh well yeah so one of the first shots i
envisioned for this video
was basically because i moved into a new
house at the beginning of this year and
i noticed the porch
kind of has the same sort of like form
factor as the porch
of the house from up except backwards
so i was like i what if i start talking
while i'm like inside my house and i
walk outside as the camera pulls
backwards to reveal
i'm standing on the porch of the house
i'm flying over the sky
so daniel and i went over to my house we
filmed it uh
yeah then clint clinton took it away
you gave me a shot yeah you gave me that
freaking intro shot
um yeah you're like yeah um
i start at my front door and i walk out
and then everything is cg around me i'm
like okay cool let's see if i can figure
this out
so that you know starts with a camera
track so i used the c4d camera tracker
and just
tracked it up nice lined up my camera
made sure the scale was right
so a default person in the program was
the size of ren
and i was like okay perfect i was like
right how much do you what's uh how much
tall how much how much are you tall and
i just line that up to like a person
you know and then luckily there was like
a model i downloaded
somewhere yeah um and i retextured it
completely
and you had to like optimize it pretty
heavily yeah yeah
because it actually it wasn't textured i
don't think when i got it so i had to
re-texture it
and then i had to line that up to ren's
body
and god what did i do after that um well
i mean
there's a few interesting things you did
with this shot but i mean first off even
before i
wrote the script like as i'm still like
trying to begin writing it you had the
entire house
ready to go including the balloons
because i had done the math and figured
out how many balloons would be needed
that was the thing too yeah i was like
can you
can you um spawn like
it was 200 000 balloons i had at one
point
to like fill it all up and make it look
freaking huge and massive
um and that was gonna be a
problem for me that was like oh crap i
don't know if i could do this
so i had to just figure out a way to
like you know clone
one item and make a copy of it but
have that copy not be more geometry it
was actually referencing the original
one so every all every single one of
those balloons were just referencing
one other balloon that's called an
instance an instance yeah so
there's technically six balloons because
there were six colors
and it was instancing all six of those
to make however many thousand hundred
thousand
and then um gave them some like
modifiers so they're kind of like moving
it's not um dynamically generated
meaning
like when you when you do like a
simulation of physics simulation it's
taking into account all the different
polygons and
doing the math between this and that and
this like it's crazy it'd break my
computer i would
be no chance so i had to just do what's
called like mograph
effects in cinema 4d which is motion
graphics and you're just taking these
points and you're just saying randomly
move them around a little bit and that's
kind of the same it was like the cheat
way to get the balloons to like
look like they're moving around and
stuff yeah but you ended up having
the collection of balloons that you see
is
technically hollow right yeah because
it's like oh really
i mean because there's no reason to
render all the balloons inside of the
hole i didn't notice
and so yeah it's like you ended up like
figuring out the
approximate volume of the whole thing
and then like just getting rid of all
the balloons inside
so you still have all like the cloner
objects around the
it still looks solid from the outside
yeah exactly so it's like
at the end of the day it basically was
like a thick shell and then you feel
that
you feel that thick shell with balloons
and then that really that number is like
you know thirty forty thousand whatever
totally yeah the ins and you can
kind of see it in in in the video uh
like you can kind of see a little like
pinpricks of light moving you can't
through the balloon and what you're
seeing is literally
you're seeing through the outer shell
and then through the back shell
or the back face of the shell to the to
the original footage in the sky
totally and whatnot and so as as we're
like you know the camera's uh
moving around the balloons the cluster
you can kind of like make out like
especially if you know what you're
looking for you can you can totally see
that technically the balloon shell is
hollow
yeah which was kind of it's kind of like
the statue of liberty
but a balloon lifting yeah exactly
thing but that's you know that's just
that's those are the short kind of
shortcuts we take to achieve these sort
of effects because it's like
you know the approximate volume is
correct yeah the uh
you know the scale of all the stuff was
set correctly how we
get it done doesn't particularly matter
and that that
that goes to what sam did for all the x
particles stuff yeah so
i guess to talk about that there's a
shot in the video where uh
i talk about what would it look like if
you actually rendered
31 million balloons in the city and then
it's like this whole epic montage of
shots that sam kicked out and there's
it's a really fun story behind that
because it's like initially i wasn't
going to have that at
all like at all oh my goodness that was
not
in the original plan for this video but
i went to sam and because i was like it
would have been cool to have it but i
didn't know how realistic it would be to
actually achieve and i didn't know how
to do it
yeah so i was like sam because sam's our
resident x particles like pro
and i was like hey is it possible to
like simulate
30 million like spheres
going around geometry and and
he was like yeah
so accurate so but and then so then he
just spent a week
just kind of experimenting and
simulating and trying a few different
things
and he has some like pretty cool looking
like test renders
but he was slowly working his way up he
started off with like a million balloons
and went up to like 5 million but then
it started crunching his computer he
couldn't simulate more than that
so what he ended up doing was i think
he ended up simulating i want to say
somewhere between like three and five
million particles
floating through a city we downloaded a
a cg model of
downtown los angeles and used the
geometry of that as like an interac like
a
interfacing thing for the for the
particles
and what he did was each particle he
replaced with a cluster of balloons
a cluster of eight balloons specifically
so every
every balloon that you see is actually a
cluster of
a few different balloons and colors so
you're actually seeing a bunch of
different little like
clusters flying through the city and
that was just a way to kind of like
get it up to that 30 million mark while
only having to simulate you know a
quarter of that
yeah it's all about the cheats yeah
exactly and so then
he came to me i was like
can't do uh interactions
because with some of the early tests
like we have the balloons like hitting
the buildings and going up and over them
and the biggest downside to the final
shots in my opinion
if you're looking they face straight
through the buildings
really oh man go back and take a look
and look at the balloons they are coming
through the buildings i didn't even
notice so sam's computer just couldn't
handle
it i forget the specific reasoning but
it's like it's just not gonna work it's
uh it's crashing it's freezing it's just
it's
he had one simulation that was like it
was gonna take like a week to simulate
and every frame was like
multiple gigabytes and he had to
simulate 7
000. oh because they're all generated in
one spot and he has to wait
for them to like flow through the city
and it takes 77
something super huge like that it was
ridiculous okay bake it you have to like
you want this render of all these
balloons in the city well you got to
simulate the balloons to get to that
point you don't just hit randomly
generate and suddenly balloons are
everywhere
yeah no they're like when i'm talking
about like the wind currents like he
literally had to simulate all the
balloons riding the wind
until they got to the city and they're
all dispersed around and then we took
that slice
yeah and that was what was in the video
yeah
it was like a lot of work to get to that
point so i told sam i was like listen
i currently have like a bear mention of
this if you can get me like one shot
that'd be great
but if you get more shots i mean i will
i will fill up this time
with however much i need to say to fit
all of the renders you give me so it's
like basically
give me whatever you can and i will try
to my best to use everything and so
he just kept kicking out renders he's
like oh yeah i read it out some more
last night i was like oh
oh and the next thing i know he's
rendered out like seven or eight shots
they're all so sick
yeah they're super sick and i was like i
guess i have to write an entire new
section for this video
uh so i did and uh i'm glad i did
because it's pretty sweet
i was really i couldn't believe that
there was that live
footage that you found oh my god yeah
balloon fest 1986.
that was the idea was that who's the
genius behind balloon fest 86
where did they think
i see what you mean now uh first
question was there a balloon fest
87 no was it was there was this
is no there was never a balloon was
there a balloon past 85
no it was just 80. it was just it was
just a one
one and done thing it was like
kidnapping one and done i don't know if
there were a smaller version previously
but they were going for a world record
for the most number of balloons released
at a time
uh-huh and uh how do you die from
setting off balloon
i'll get to that it's so like they must
have overshot that world record by like
a ton
right they didn't die the way you would
expect
so uh oh i know it was a car crash no no
no okay
okay i'll tell the story so they
released all these balloons they were
going for world record they had
guinness world record officials there
chicago was it
cleveland cleveland cleveland ohio and
they released all the balloons a little
early because there's a storm front that
was coming through that was like
really cold air and it was pressing they
they're like
yeah storm front was coming through and
they're like we gotta release these now
so they're releasing them a little early
they only got like one and a half
million balloons
and and yeah and so they released all
the balloons you get the epic shot of
them going out in the city but then
the storm comes in with a cold front in
front of it
and it basically changed the the density
of the air so that all the helium just
fell to the ground
and uh littered the ocean
littered the skies with balloons
everywhere and there were two fishermen
that were lost at sea
they had they had gotten to an accident
or something like that
out in the sea and helicopters couldn't
fly through the storm
of balloons like literally they
the the helicopter couldn't approach so
coast guard couldn't go rescue these
fishermen
who died oh my god because they weren't
imagine being a kid being like this is
the happiest thing in the world
there's a million balloons that are
about to go off
and then nobody bothered to ask the
question of like hey
this probably isn't good no i shut down
the entire city for like a couple days a
million
pieces of rubber just like we're just
gonna just
dump them yeah and then like no thought
given to like yeah and so for these kids
apparently they were degradable these
lost fishermen are like
oh my god please somebody
balloons all around the cops you're
saying these balloons come from can't
fly in there because this engine's gonna
get wrapped in
yeah they're just out there they're just
trapped out there and then it's like
it's like three days later they're like
dude i think we're gonna die it's like
why can't anyone it's like
why can't they send anybody just 86.
they just they sell out those balloons
yeah it was like they
apparently this guy wanted to shut off
the balloons and so they can't come get
us
so yeah i mean and that's okay oh it's
terrible i don't mean to laugh but oh my
god i know i know right it's it's sad
they said it was biodegradable but don't
biodegradable materials take like
forever to degrade
anyways i i i don't know what kind of
materials they're using biodegradable
you're right it could take maybe a
hundred years for it to like decompose
it could take
maybe they're like sugar based and it
takes like a few days i don't know
dude in the 80s biodegradable could have
been anything
yeah and
but yeah so it shut down the city
because suddenly you had balloons
landing everywhere they couldn't they
had to shut down the highways they shut
down the airports i want to see
like the hectic street where it's like
so i did i think i made one mistake i
said uh
no one ever tried something like that
again but apparently at like disney
world in the uk or something like that
uh several years later they attempted
something like that again
whatever i don't know whatever someone
was like oh yeah you did your research
huh
i was like whatever fine doesn't matter
um dang dude people are salty
yeah is it on twitter or is it on
youtube i don't know it's
uh yeah don't don't don't worry about
this man
just know that if there's if there's
salt in there it means that at least
people are watching it
yeah no for sure for sure but like the
worst part about all of that
they did not get the world record what
they refused to issue
the record why but i don't know why
maybe because it ended up being such a
danger to the the city that they're like
we can't condone this
we're not giving you the record
technically you definitely beat the
record but we're not giving you our
oh i'd be pissed yeah dude i know here's
the thing
here's here's what actually happened the
event director
knew about how he knew about the
stranded fisherman
but he didn't care
wait i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
you are releasing my balloons on my cue
knock you only there's like a guy's like
finger on the button like nukes
oh my god dude that's how did they
release those was everybody just like
holding a ball
no they're under a giant net so they had
erected this giant net
they just had 200 people like
for seven days straight well i mean they
i mean
they inhaled the helium and then
yeah it could be legit it had to go
through a human body first
oh yeah so yeah that was the thing that
was uh
that was a big deal the drama behind
that like i would love to see the movie
dude oh my god a netflix drama series
seriously it starts and it's got like
dark and brooding music
you just see a cloud of balloons
approaching the camera
oh my god it's like the silhouetted
person with the
voice changer it's basically chernobyl
but with balloons
yes yes yes they have to take up all the
topsoil because it's covered
both in 86 that's it
oh my god yeah so like you know we're
running out of helium so
every every like macy's day parade
macy's day thanksgiving macy's
yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll just switch to
hydrogen
let's just parade a bunch of bombs down
the middle of the street
down the middle of fifth avenue
uh what's the deal with that what
happens what's gonna happen there
so yeah so the problem with helium is
that it's lighter than air so it floats
out into space
like if it's like all the helium i just
uh breathed out you know like
it's in here it's it's diffused
throughout all the air but eventually
it's gonna make its way outside
and then make its way up into the
stratosphere and then up into the very
top layer of
the atmosphere where there's like no
other molecules around it literally
escapes to outer space
it's that lightweight can we go up there
and like capture it somehow i don't
think so i don't think it's because
it's not remotely dense enough to
capture up there
so and i never knew this for the longest
time until like a couple of years ago i
learned that like oh yeah we
we drill for healing we get it out of
the ground we mine it
that sounds like pain and so then before
this video i was researching how that
exactly works and it's like apparently
uranium
uh because it's like radioactive decay
it's like shooting off
uh ions and whatnot and those ions end
up forming helium so it's not
radioactive
it's just because helium is the second
lightest element it's literally just
like
i think a proton and like two electrons
or something like that
so this is a two proton it's a proton
and neutron like two
two electrons yeah i forget i'm i have
to like turn in my chemistry card right
now
um no it's two because it's hydrogen and
then helium yeah so it's like
number two i was saying like the number
of uh neutrons
protons then it would have to have two
protons yeah it's definitely two protons
but i don't know if it i'm pretty sure
it's two electrons and then two neutrons
maybe it's one neutron wait so it says
uranus what is uranium in its purest
form like what is that what does that
look like it's a rock
yeah it's like more or less it's like a
rocky metal it's just
yeah i mean kind of it's it's a mineral
if you're to look at some uranium it
just looks like a rocky mineral type
thing but it's just it has a it's
radioactive
whoa and uh but we're talking like you
know thousands of feet underground
and that's so crazy so it's producing
this helium
and that helium seeks through the cracks
and and whatnot and then forms with all
the natural gas that is already down
there and has been forming over the
course of millions of years so anytime
do the miners just start talking in
high-pitched voices oh we're into some
good [ __ ] here
yeah the weirdest thing about the
weirdest thing about chemistry is that
we don't even
like why is it radioactive uh
you we can say because because it has
this compound and this compound
and those and those two things you know
cause radioactivity or whatever but like
beyond that yeah
yeah that's so crazy i mean we i mean
kind of know why
like it's it's i mean how do you explain
it well i mean
i don't know well enough to explain it
but like it definitely is explainable
in pretty extreme detail how and why it
works but it
kind of seems like the why you're asking
is like like why do we exist
like what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying is like chemistry has some of
that inherent to it like
when you you can take one you know
compound
and combine it with another and then
this will happen or that'll happen and
we can explain what's likely to happen
or we can explain what we know
to happen but if you're going to combine
like hydrogen and helium or whatever
like the the react the result of
why those things you could say yeah
because it's missing a proton and the
protons are cut or
because it's missing an electron and
they you know and they're they're
looking for
that it's it's unstable but why is it
unstable well because it's not
balanced well why is it not balanced
like that those are like we don't know
those no we do know those
all of those answers are pretty well
documented i think what jake is trying
to say
but like what constitutes the rules of
the universe like we don't know
why these rules are in place yeah that's
what i'm saying
sure but that's why i said like like
it's that's more of an existential
question
that's a very interesting question
though yeah it is it's like i was just
trying to blow clint's mind man
yeah it's crazy because it's like every
now and then i i start realizing how the
universe works and it's like
all of these crazy elements that we have
were born in a supernova
we are literally stardust like the
famous uh neil degrasse tyson line where
he's like
you and i are made of stardust cool dude
um
but like it's it's true though it's like
you know at the beginning of the
universe there's a ton of hydrogen it
was basically just a whole bunch of
hydrogen that all collapsed
into stars and when those stars exploded
the the pressure from an exploding star
is so great at its core that it fuses
those elements into heavier elements
so like iron you know gold all of the
all the elements we know of
were literally it's like you had like
these two ladder elements of like
say i don't know what's what's like
carbon you know some sort of lighter
element
uh is there just a couple carbon
elements hanging out
and then like an explosion happens
around you and those things are pushed
together so hard
they form iron wow and then are just
blasted into space just like imagine
like the most
highest resolution dust simulation
possible it's just a ton of dust
covering
light years and then slowly over the
course of like a billion years it
compresses back down
and then like forms back up but all of
the heavier stuff doesn't move as fast
so it kind of stays out because it's got
inertia right it's it's harder to move
and all the hydrogen collapses back down
to the center forms a new star
all of the heavier elements they stay
out in space but eventually they start
forming up into planets
wow and and so that's how you get like
the planets the rocky
iron uh all the other elements they just
start
grouping together because they've got
you know gravity they eventually meet up
and and yeah and that's how we get all
of
everything that's so wild and it's crazy
because it's like
the sun accounts for 99 of all the mass
in the solar system
and like jupiter accounts for like point
nine percent of all of the mass in our
0.09 of all the masses in our solar
system in our solar system yeah it's
like the sun is like 99.9
of all the mass oh goodness it's like
and it's like when you think about that
it's like imagine space out there
yeah well i mean like but like think of
it this way it's like you're you're
you're done you spilled a bunch of dust
on the ground right and and it's like
you're you're wiping it all up and you
get those last little bits that you
can't get into the dustpan
and you pull it back a little bit does
more pull back a little bit dust more
and eventually you're like all right i
got enough of it
i got 99.9 of all the dust that i just
spilled
and you pour that into the trash well
the trash is now your sun and all the
other particles that you didn't quite
get
forms primarily jupiter followed by
saturn
and then like a few microscopic specks
that you didn't get that forms earth
that's crazy that's a good analogy
i mean that's what nasa wants you to
believe
that's it's a conspiracy man
they'll have us believe hilarious yeah
if you just think about it in the terms
of just like it's just a bunch of dust
that explodes out and then the inertia
of that dust is different between
different elements
and then that just happens over and over
again that's how you get all these
different stars and then eventually it
gets to a big enough scale that
galaxies form because you get all these
little tiny things that are all clumping
together because of gravity
and also like dark matter and dark
energy which i don't know much about but
that's a huge favorite
don't talk to me about dark matter dude
but yeah
it's like it's crazy yeah so hydrogen
there's a lot of hydrogen in the
universe there's a lot of helium in the
universe there's tons
of helium out there it's just there's
not much of it on earth
where does it go when it's in the vacuum
of space
it just probably chills up at the top
layer of our atmosphere
it's like it's light enough that it
reaches the top of the atmosphere
but it's not weightless it doesn't
escape out into space oh so our gravity
our gravity keeps it it's an orbit it's
probably it just sits up there
i wouldn't say it's an orbit it's
literally just like directly above us
like
a hundred miles i wonder could you sift
it in the future could you sift it and
potentially yeah maybe if we had like
nano bots
or something yeah in theory you could
but it's like we're talking like at
densities that are
so low it's not worth doing you're
better off going to jupiter and sifting
it out from there
mm-hmm cool yeah
nah dude is it's great so okay going
back to visual effects
how are we doing right now we're good
peter i wanted you to talk about maybe a
shot or two that you did exactly no i'm
bringing it over i'm bringing that up
right now so
going into this video i specifically
wanted to not use a green screen
for this video oh no
i walk out of my my living room door
because you know rotoscoping isn't that
bad
we can do it and this whole new machine
learning runway ml thing where you just
click a person suddenly the rotoscoped
in two and a half minutes i was like oh
cool
i wanna i wanna see how feasible this is
for an actual production
yeah so uh on a sunday i i set up a
camera on my porch and i i filmed all of
my porch bits sitting on my chair
with the idea that i will cut out the
the porch and my body and we'll replace
it with a drone shot
you know as if i'm up in the air it
seemed like a great idea so i was like
okay
you didn't use a green screen for that
son no
i'm glad it wasn't noticeable yeah no no
one person one person commented i forget
if it was a youtube comment or an
instagram message but he was like
you should really dispel your footage
dude i can see the green screen peeking
through around your edges that's like
you should use like light wrap and stuff
on it like
your green screen key would have looked
better i'm like
well they probably saw the grass they
probably saw the grass
no i don't think they saw the grass i
think they're seeing artifacts through
the hair because there are a couple
moments where
you can see my hair so yeah i
threw peter under the bus here by under
the bus i mean i just like
hey peter i'm giving you a week's worth
of rotoscoping yeah i mean honestly it
wasn't that bad i just think
you uh overestimated the potential of
runway ml and rotobrush too
that was what we learned so tell me
about your experience yeah so
how well does runway ml work runway ml
the green screen model specifically
works fantastic for people um but the
problem
is it's only 1080p and so when you bring
in your rotoscope like your cutout image
into after effects to use to separate
your background from your foreground
it's very you have those jagged edges
and when you go to smooth out those
edges you lose detail on the corners
so all of the little like the corner
right here and in between your hands and
fingers and stuff
you get the little white background in
between there so it's not as high
resolution
and also it really only works great for
people
for like objects i don't know like nico
hasn't had
trouble with this but i would try and
like select a chair and it'd be like nah
and then i'm gonna try and select it
again and be like all right and it would
do it and then track three frames
perfect
and then it'd be like nah i don't
attract the chair
i'm done that's the biggest downside
with that that program i can see right
now is that like it's so early on
in the in the the time scale of like
these sort of things is that like
yeah the way it works is by training you
know like a deep fake
uh you train it on someone on two people
and it just basically looks at thousands
of images
and tries to make that image over and
over and over again until it starts
getting pretty decent
yeah it's the same sort of thing with
the green screen effect basically you
give it an image and then you also give
it a rotoscoped image
and it compares the two and learns where
those rotoscoped lines are going
and you just do that enough times that
it's starting to figure out okay i think
i know how this works
but i guarantee you they trained
primarily on people yeah which makes
sense because that's primarily the
like most the time if you're rotoscoping
you're rotoscoping out people
exactly um and it works great and what
it works perfect for is when we did that
runwayml video with clint doing the uh
the
crazy dancing uh and the explosion
behind him it works
perfect for things like that where some
things like moving erratically and you
have to put something behind them for
like a second
it's perfect yeah but if you're just
like sitting on a porch talking at a
camera for
a minute straight it starts to fall
apart a little bit well you were
actually talking about the idea that
you can rough roto something if it's
moving
quickly like you just you literally just
said this but i think i think
this is it's something very important no
totally because i know exactly what you
mean
you can roto someone roughly if they're
moving quickly
because you don't have your eyes don't
have time to focus on
the inconsistencies and the errors yeah
totally um
because oh it might be an error here but
like you didn't see it because it's
moving so fast
this was there for a split second yeah
but when it's just me sitting here and
i'm like explaining this like you're
going to see like
the wobbly edges and the yeah it gives
your eyes more time to be like wait
what's going on there yeah especially
when it's
sitting above like hundreds of feet
above the ground and you're like oh my
god
especially as i'm leaning back in my
chair giving everyone freaking anxious
those shots when you like tripped back
when i watched the original footage i
was like what is ren doing in the shot
and then i put the drone footage in
and i was like oh that's cool you did
that on purpose right
kind of kind of so i set myself up in a
situation
where it could happen but i didn't know
when it would happen
it took several takes for it to finally
happen i'll put it that way
so hey so runway ml um you should
tell nico the what you guys discovered
there oh yeah
yeah okay because they'd like us to
we've been talking with them a little
bit and they'd like us to
like you know help help them suss out
problems like that
absolutely i mean yeah i don't mean to
talk [ __ ] about runway ml it's a great
piece of software and it's
extremely helpful just for that
particular project yeah we ended up well
so runaway mail is a platform
and the model we use what we're talking
about
they'd be happy to hear us to hear us
tell them that because that's
that's a prime example yeah no for sure
and i'm sure we'll talk about it because
uh that was part of the reason why i
wanted to do this project this way is to
learn
on an actual project how feasible it is
by just doing the project that was a
good thing and uh yeah
and yeah and so what you ended up having
to do was combining that
or did you do entirely rotobrush too
yeah so what ended up happening was i
tried doing runwayml for your whole body
and it worked decently for getting your
arms and your legs and stuff but then
the head
it smoothed over your hair and you got
little corners
on your ears and things like that yeah
and since the face and the eyes is the
first thing you look at and the thing
you look at the most in a shot
it was the most noticeable there so for
the head i would do that with rota brush
where i could select the head get the
ears all nice and crispy
and then you use the refine edge tool on
the hair and you actually
get that transparent hair like the
individual strands which
i don't know how the heck it works it's
amazing it's kind of magic it's like
like amazing the whole video was like oh
this runway ml thing is pretty sweet and
all but like
like the refine edge tool in rotobrush 2
is actually pretty dang great yeah it's
uh i remember when the it first came out
back in like 2013 rotobrush was already
a thing at that time but then the refine
edge came out
and i used it a whole bunch on like
clothes and and like
things i was like this is this is
amazing yeah it is magic i don't know
how it works but then it's like
you start learning the limitations of it
and you're like i hate it
sometimes it's just dumb yeah sometimes
any of these sort of that's the problem
with ai tools is that like you don't
have that much control like
fine detail control over them it's great
whenever it works
yeah and if you give it something that
is good at doing it's going to do it
very well
but you give it something it can't
really do very well it's gonna struggle
for instance
the chair is sitting on yeah if you like
toss it underhand a softball it'll hit
it every single time
but the moment you throw a fastball it's
like
but again this is this comes down to
simply
time training this is the beginning of
this model this model is going to
continue to train on a bunch of variety
of objects like
if they threw more like heat out chairs
it'd be like oh this is what a chair
looks like
oh this is what a car looks like like
all these different things and over time
the library of knowledge that this model
has grows
totally so i'm i'm i would not be
surprised if in a year
it's pretty dang robust yeah it's not
like their software is inherently flawed
or anything it just needs more time
yeah yeah yeah exactly machine learning
is so wild like that like how it's
they how you can just take in additional
information and then
give it back to the model to improve
itself and then yeah
have it go out again and and dig again
and it's wild it's like and that's that
is the cool thing about
runway ml is that it is a machine
learning platform you can design your
own models and put it up on the platform
for other people to use and train
well that's really cool yeah that is
cool but the green screen effect that
they use
is is an in-house produced model they
made it themselves and we've already
i've already seen two other videos that
talk about it action vfx did a video
about it and
film right did a video about it great
videos um but like they actually vfx guy
uh luke he he did three roto shots in 10
minutes
jeez and they weren't like simple rotors
he one he's like coming out of the water
running to shore
one he's like quickly running through a
hallway like bouncing off the walls
and it's like a few clicks done i it's
like
yeah pretty great but like you're saying
if i'm just sitting here for five
minutes on a chair
uh yeah those straight lines doesn't
like the straight lines rotor brushes
doesn't like straight lines either and
it's just like
but also the moment when i fall off my
chair or almost fall out of the chair
and i lean forward the chair i'm sitting
on has a mesh bit behind my back
and if you look at that mesh you can
clearly see my garden
yeah but it's a nice combination of
brown and green
and red that it kind of just looks like
the drone footage
yeah the color grade you threw on helped
a lot to match the two
but yeah it honestly wasn't too bad got
to listen to a lot of podcasts
but uh yeah but that means you also
kicked out some
really really cool uh carbon fiber
thanks no just shout out to
freakingpolygon.com for that texture
yeah
yeah dude the only place like i i was
like oh man
what place has a carbon fiber texture
and science doesn't
mega skins doesn't um like freaking i
don't know textures.com or something
no you're like the mega skins
i think that was one of uh because you
told me that like most of their textures
they do these days
and have been for a while substance
they're all substance designed right
they're all made from scratch because
it's like
all right he can pay someone to go photo
scan uh
a material and that takes you know x
amount of time x amount of dollars
and it's not that much but all of that
leads to one material
or he can pay someone a little bit more
to put in all this effort to make this
one material that now with just a couple
like
like changes of seeds and inputs yeah
you can get a
completely different material and so
with that
same basically the same amount of work
you can produce 30 materials
or 30 million materials you know it's
like there's not really an upper limit
or yeah that's why substance designer is
so incredible yeah
i want to learn substance designer i've
been doing substance painter for a while
but that's more just like individual
objects as opposed to creating a
like a material substance designer is so
much fun
really it is i dived in for like two
weeks and i was like this is
awesome this is the best man like
they've just been here all day
that's cool i gotta check that out yeah
no it's it's cool stuff but yeah uh i so
i don't i think they
they probably produce that carbon fiber
material but there's only one carbon
fiber material
mm-hmm that's all you need so what's the
substance andrew leave a comment down
below
um what was i going to say no jake was
about to say something
but but i mean yeah so it's like the
whole thing about the carbon fiber thing
is that i feel like carbon fiber as a
visual is a very
recognizable material everyone's
familiar with that cross weave
shiny blackness yeah that is totally not
indestructible absolutely 100
will and is and always has been
indestructible
thank you jake yes got it because
again like this whole segment is is like
a thought experiment about like all
right if you could have a material
that's mega strong and literally doesn't
weigh anything
uh like what would that look like
chances are it'd probably just be like
jet black
like it wouldn't look like anything and
it's like well that's boring
so yeah i mean like and especially the
scale of the carbon fiber totally
doesn't
match between all the shots oh no the
ratio is whack
i didn't notice though i had no idea but
no like it was intentional on my part i
was like make it big enough that you can
clearly see because technically like
the smaller balloon that you see is like
uh if you were to stick with that scale
of of carbon fiber texture
and but blow that up to the size of the
one that's holding the house it would
just be like this fine moire type
pattern
and same thing if you go backwards if
you're to use the scale of the big
balloon
down on the small balloon either the one
that friggin david blaine was hanging
from or the freaking collapsible one
you would have like one giant strip
going around the whole balloon and one
giant strip going the other way and it's
like
looks like garbage too but that's a good
like uh creative
note there as you chose to go for what
looks cool versus
yeah being realistic yeah it's like not
necessarily what looks cool as much as
just what looks recognizable i wanted it
to be instantly like oh that's a carbon
fiber balloon people associate carbon
fiber with being lightweight
there's also a material that caught
light really nicely like it caught the
sunlight wrapping around
all those little things the whole thing
where you projected the footage onto a
plane so they actually had proper
reflection dude in the
the shadow displacement that was a
shadow thing i figured out it's so good
i tried that on the the statue of
liberty shot but it just wasn't working
dang yeah what what is what shadow this
was if okay so you rent out render out
your beauty pass which is like the main
cgi element and then you render out your
shadow pass and you throw
you know one on top of the other and for
your shadow in after effects
if you place a displacement map effect
on it and then set the displacement
image to like your main footage it'll
use
the brightness values in your background
footage to like push
the pixels of the shadow in like little
different directions
so it looks like like if there's grass
in your shot or something it looks like
some of the grass is like peeking up
above the shadow and kind of distorting
it a little bit
it gives it a really nice like yeah like
when it goes over the waves and on the
ground you can actually it kind of looks
like it's going up and
over the wave or over the so it actually
gives the shadow depth as opposed to
just
a perfectly flat plane which is how we
always
render out our shadows on a perfectly
flat surface and even if it is like a
mostly flat surface it's never perfectly
flat dude that's a level nine
tip dude but it's one of those tips
where it's like so simple but it helps
so much it's great
it works well for that shot because the
object wasn't
contacting the shadow though because i
tried doing that on the statue of
liberty shot where it starts
starts out really close up on the house
and then pulls away to reveal the statue
of liberty in hindenburg
but those shadows are in contact with
those those objects
and so the moment i tried that it was
pulling away from the
actual house itself so i was having some
separation issues
i had a lot of trouble separating
although i did i was telling clint about
this this morning i did
manage to get some grass growing in
front of the bottom of the house go back
and look at that it's like
like if you're to freeze frame on the
opening shot i'm really happy with that
render because
the house actually looks like it's
sitting there in a yard because you got
pieces of grass going up
through the like the steps going down
into the into the grass
in front of it yeah and i did that by
basically rendering out a shadow mat of
a plane with
hair growing on it so i just simulated a
whole bunch of hair
sprouting out of this ground plane and i
just put that underneath the house
and the hair intersects with the house
and everything in front of the house it
blocks it
so i rendered that out as a shadow
catcher material that i just used as
in after effects to cut away like cookie
cut out
the house render so it sounds to me like
both of you guys
did the same thing but through a
different way a little bit yeah
yeah i didn't really do much for the
shadow going out over that was more for
the render rather than the shadow
but it's it's all a way to try to just
take something that you rendered
in in a flawless environment and try to
like
rough it up rough it up in a realistic
way yeah it's all about roughing your
stuff up yeah it comes out all sterile
and clean and then you have to like
throw grain on it and make it look like
it was shot on your knees
iron man one looked so good compared to
all the other iron man movies he's all
freaking gritty and scratched up that's
my main complaint with iron man is that
like you know back in the early ones he
still had like a metal suit whereas in
the later ones he got like this freaking
nanoparticle suit yeah
and they changed the the texture to be
more of like a
matte reflective type thing very kind of
like a rough edge
as opposed to like a sharp reflection
yeah and it just kind of made it look
more unrealistic to me okay i agree
uh whereas like you know iron man 1 even
iron man 2 iron man 2 visuals were
really good
german 3 visuals were very good uh and
it's like
they got a little at hand but they still
like a lot of those shots were like
i don't know i also wasn't the biggest
fan of the beige styles like
yeah but those cg suits looked
very good that's true that's true
anyway uh yeah so a lot of a lot of the
effects came together in this video i
was realizing this video had a
tremendous number of visual effects
because
we had the three of you guys you two and
sam
i contributed one shot this is the
fewest number of vfx shots i've ever
done on one of my videos
uh if you don't include all like the
other random effects that i do inside of
premiere like with the text and whatnot
but uh
i reused a lot of old effects i reused
the shot that you did for the world of
warships
video talking about buoyancy yeah uh i
included our freaking
uh what was the video the metal gear
solid video the balloon ride
and those were a bunch of vfx shots that
we had done
i'm so glad we got to reuse those yeah
especially since you're the character i
know right
that is me dangling from the balloon
yeah and no one knows
i even included a shot of me but you
just can't tell that it's me because
i've got a mask
that's a great video man yeah i'm proud
of you yeah it was
it was and uh everyone yeah
everyone really i think like
had a chance to show off some strengths
and uh
you know if you guys want to hear first
on the corridor cast the tips and tricks
how to make it nitty gritty how to make
it
lifelike um you know all that good stuff
uh just uh come on down subscribe to the
corridor cast because we got plenty more
of this
on the way yeah come visit the studio
stop by
come hang me hey no no no if you come i
can't say that you can't say that
yeah gosh dang it here's the thing
here's the thing you still get people
dropping by the studio we do not
appreciate rando's coming by the studio
like there's other ways to do it however
not rando's fans
if you yeah i apologies if you're coming
out of the studio
while we're working okay like we're busy
okay
if you come down to this son no you're
gonna cut this out i know it but like
we're not gonna we don't cut anything
anymore if you're gonna come down to the
studio
and be like oh let's get a tour while
everyone's working
very hard bring something for us bring
something closer
bring us food bring us bring us
something bring us gifts
bring me bitcoin bring us gifts
these don't come down to the studio
on a tuesday afternoon
we'll be working and making a video
but if you want to listen to the podcast
or leave a comment on ren's video
we'll be there
we'll be there
we'll be there i like this trend of
talking about videos that we just put
out though i think we should keep doing
it so definitely subscribe
and uh i'll see you guys in another
video
hey hey hit the million helium zone yeah
some helium for a million views the full
exhale you need the light seal
thanks for
thanks watching watching we'll see you
next week we have oh wait
this is what you gotta do you gotta try
to talk really deeply exhale pull exhale
this is me trying to talk
i have i have i
am if i start trying to talk like this
it just sounds different
inhale helium and then yell and yell i'm
going to try to yell that's a good idea
let me get a little bit of hair
i'm going to assume that we faded out at
this point yeah exhale completely
exhale completely and full that's what i
did that's why i almost passed out do it
again dude no i'm not doing that again
i'm cutting son i'm cutting